I have, you know,
been in the back seat
of an F-15 on a combat mission.
I've been in the
streets of Baghdad.
I've been a moderator
at presidential debates.
There is nothing that has been
more meaningful in my career
than this.
When I first met all these
soldiers, and then later
their spouses, and sat them
down for interviews-- and I'd
heard the story.
I was not in the battle.
And the reporters were all so
caught up in covering policy,
or covering where
were the WMDs, where
was this, that we'd forgotten
there was a war going on.
We were so busy covering the
effects of going into war,
when I heard those
stories about this battle,
I said, we have to do it.
Americans have become used
to hearing about casualties.
They've become used to mass
casualties with our military.
But this was one of the
first times this had
happened to us as Americans.
If you-- you have to think
back what that was like.
These soldiers had no clue they
were going to end up in combat.
No clue at all.
They were fathers, husbands.
Their wives-- that
emotional goodbye.
They thought they were going
to keep the peace over there.
If they had really
known what would happen,
that would have been a much,
much, more difficult scene.
I think I was also surprised
because even though all
the actors talk about finding
the essence of the character--
they don't want
to be exactly what
the real people were like--
I was surprised
how close they came
to those characters and
the soldiers and the wives
that I know.
They really did capture
who those people are.
You cannot look at them recreate
those scenes and recreate those
characters and not
think of the real
soldiers and the real families
and what they went through.
[music playing]